THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
♪ ♪
>> I HAVE OPPOSED HIS
NOMINATION.
>> FROM THE BEGINNING --
>> I'VE OPPOSED IT FROM THE
BEGINNING.
I THINK THE NOMINATION SHOULD BE
WITHDRAWN.
>> I STRONGLY BELIEVE JUDGE
KAVANAUGH SHOULD WITHDRAW FROM
CONSIDERATION.
AND THE PRESIDENT SHOULD
WITHDRAW THIS NOMINATION IF
KAVANAUGH WON'T DO IT
VOLUNTARILY.
>> I JOIN LEADER SCHUMER AND
CALLING FOR JUDGE KAVANAUGH TO
WITHDRAW HIS NAME FROM
CONSIDERATION.
>> Laura: TRACKER.
WE TOLD YOU THIS WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THE LONGER THE REPUBLICANS ALLOW
BRETT KAVANAUGH TO TWIST IN THE
WIND, THE MORE CONCESSIONS THEY
GRANTED TO HIS LAST-MINUTE
ACCUSERS, THE UGLIER IT IS GOING
TO GET.
YOU KNOW IN MUSICALS, THE 11:00
NUMBER ALWAYS ARRIVES RIGHT ON
TIME TO CLOSE AT THE SHOW?
WELL, THE 11:00 NUMBER IN THE
KAVANAUGH CONFIRMATION SAGA HAS
ARRIVED.
[DRUMROLL]
OH, HE LOOKS ADORABLE ON THAT
STAGE.
MICHAEL AVENATTI DELIVERS A GIFT
TODAY.
HE DRAFTED AN AFFIDAVIT IN WHICH
THIS WOMAN, JULIE SWETNICK,
GILLETTE, CLAIMS THAT KAVANAUGH,
WILEY HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT IN THE
EARLY '80s, SPIKED DRINKS AT
HOUSE PARTIES TO LOOSEN GIRLS
INHIBITIONS ARE THEN ESSENTIALLY
GROOMED THEM TO BE GANG RAPED
INSIDE ROOMS BRADY FAIRLY
ALLEGES THAT KAVANAUGH WAS
PRESENT AT ONE SUCH PARTY IN
APPROXIMATELY 1982 WHEN SHE
WAS GANG, THOUGH SHE SAYS HE
DIDN'T TAKE PART IN IT.
SWETNICK CLAIMS THERE ARE
WITNESSES THAT CAN VOUCH FOR HER
ACCOUNT.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD FROM THEM.
REACTING TO THOSE OUTRAGEOUS
CHARGES, KAVANAUGH SAID THE
FOLLOWING.
"THIS IS RIDICULOUS AND FROM THE
TWILIGHT ZONE.
I DON'T KNOW WHO THIS IS AND
THIS NEVER HAPPENED."
NOW THIS IS THE THIRD IN A
SERIES OF WHAT CERTAINLY APPEARS
TO BE A CAREFULLY TIMED AND
COORDINATED SMEAR CAMPAIGN ON
KAVANAUGH.
FIRST THERE WAS CHRISTINE BLASEY
FORD, WHO IS STILL SCHEDULED, AS
I SAID, TO TESTIFY TOMORROW
MORNING BEFORE THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
EXACTLY NO ONE HAS CORROBORATED
HER CLAIMS AND THE POLYGRAPH
TEST THAT SHE SUBMITTED TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TODAY, IT
READ LIKE IT WAS CONDUCTED BY
CORY BOOKER.
WE HAVE MORE ON THAT IN A FEW
MOMENTS.
THEN FROM STATE FOR THE LOVE
CAME SOCIAL JUSTICE ADVOCATE
DEBORAH L PACK
DEBORAH RAMIREZ, WHO CLAIMED
THAT KAVANAUGH EXPOSED HIMSELF
TO HER DURING THEIR FRESHMAN
YEAR AT YALE.
RAMIREZ MAY HAVE EXPOSED THE
HOLES IN HER OWN STORY BY
ADMITTING TO FANS THAT SHE
COULDN'T BE SURE IF
KAVANAUGH WAS THE GUILTY PARTY.
THERE ARE NO CORROBORATING
WITNESSES.
KAVANAUGH HAS DENIED THAT IT
HAPPENED AND RAMIREZ HERSELF
ADMITS TO BEING BUMPED, SLURRING
HER WORDS OF THE TIME, AND
SHE CONCEDED THAT HER MEMORY WAS
"FOGGY."
THEN TODAY, WE SAW A NEW
ADDITION TO THE PLAYBILL.
MRS. SWETNICK.
NOW LIKE THE OTHER TWO HEROINES
OF THE ANTI-KAVANAUGH
RESISTANCE, HER ALLEGATIONS ARE
ALREADY GETTING BAD REVIEWS.
SHE SAYS SHE ATTENDED AT LEAST
TEN PARTIES WHERE GANG-RAPES
WERE TAKING PLACE.
SHE ALSO SAID SHE WENT BACK TO
ONE SUCH PARTY IN APPROXIMATELY
1982 AFTER KNOWING THAT THESE BE
THESE BE 21s WERE TAKING
PLACE, WHERE THEN SHE HERSELF
WAS RAPED.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE IN 1982,
SHE WAS A SOPHOMORE IN COLLEGE.
HOW MANY COLLEGE STUDENTS DO YOU
KNOW WHO ATTEND HIGH SCHOOL
FUNCTIONS WHERE GANG-RAPES HAD
PREVIOUSLY OCCURRED?
NONE OF IT MAKES MUCH SENSE AT
ALL.
BUT THIS DOES.
TONIGHT WE ARE LEARNING A LOT
MORE ABOUT AVENATTI'S NEW PRIZE,
MS. SWETNICK.
ACCORDING TO POLITICO, HER
EX-BOYFRIEND PAINTS A DISTURBING
PICTURE OF HER OWN CHARACTER.
IN A PHONE INTERVIEW WITH
"POLITICO," HE SAID THIS ABOUT
HIS 2001 INJUNCTION.
RIGHT AFTER I BROKE UP WITH HER,
SWETNICK, SHE WAS THREATENING MY
FAMILY, MY WIFE, THREATENING
TO DO HARM TO MY BABY AT THAT
TIME.
I KNOW A LOT ABOUT HER.
SHE'S NOT CREDIBLE AT ALL."
HE SAID NOT AT ALL.
WOW.
DESPITE ALL OF THAT, OF COURSE
THE MEDIA TODAY DID WHAT THEY
ALWAYS DO, TRY TO MAKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP OUT TO BE ABOUT
GOING ALL THIS.
ANOTHER CHOREOGRAPHED
PERFORMANCE.
>> IF YOU DON'T MIND COME AFTER
I AM FINISHED, IF ONE OF OUR
FEMALE COLLEAGUES COULD GO AFTER
ME, THAT WOULD BE GREAT FOR
GREAT FOR YOU TO DOES THAT MEAN?
'S THINK IT WOULD BE GREAT IF A
FEMALE --
>> WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
>> I THINK IT WOULD BE GREAT IF
A FEW MY REPORTER WOULD ASK YOU
A QUESTION ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
IF YOU DON'T MIND --
>> I WOULDN'T MIND IT AT ALL.
IT WOULDN'T MAKE ANY DIFFERENCE
TO ME.
>> A FOLLOW UP ON A QUESTION
THAT A COLLEAGUE ASKED.
I WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON JIM'S
QUESTION.
MR. PRESIDENT, LET ME FOLLOW UP
ON JIM'S QUESTION THAT I DON'T
THINK HE GOT AN ANSWER TO.
>> Laura: NO COLLUSION THERE.
THE PRESIDENT, THOUGH, HE WASN'T
RATTLED BY THE STORM.
HE GAVE HIS OWN KIND OF INSTANT
REVIEW OF THESE LAST-MINUTE
THEATRICS.
>> IT'S A VERY TOUGH SITUATION
FOR A WOMAN.
THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR A STORY.
WE ARE GIVING YOUR TIME.
THEY WILL HAVE A BIG SHOT AT
SPEAKING AND MAKING THE CASE.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I COULD BE PERSUADED ALSO.
I THINK WHEN YOU REALLY LOOK AT
IT ALL, IT'S NOT GOING TO CHANGE
ANY OF THE DEMOCRATS' MINDS.
THEY ARE OBSTRUCTIONISTS.
THEY ARE ACTUALLY CON ARTISTS
BECAUSE THEY KNOW HOW QUALITY
THIS MAN IS AND MAY HAVE
DESTROYED A MAN'S REPUTATION AND
THEY WANT TO DESTROY IT EVEN
MORE.
THEY KNOW IT'S A BIG, FAT CON
JOB, AND THEY GO INTO A ROOM,
AND I GUARANTEE YOU, THEY LAUGH
LIKE HELL ON WHAT THEY PULLED
OFF ON YOU AND THE PUBLIC.
THEY LAUGH LIKE HELL.
>> Laura: I THOROUGHLY ENJOYED
THE PRESS CONFERENCE AT THE U.N.
THE ENTIRE ALLEGATION ACT IS
GETTING OLD FOR THE LAST MINUTE
SOLOS ARE NOT CREDIBLE IN THE
REPORTERS SCORES FROM A FALLING
FLAT.
MY PRODUCTION, AFTER ALL THE
HYPE, AFTER A BRIGHT LIGHTS, ALL
OF IT HAS FADED, AFTER WE HAVE
HEARD FROM THE LEFT ABOUT
THE KAVANAUGH TAKEDOWN EFFORT,
ALL OF IT, THIS PRODUCTION WILL
CLOSE OUT OF TOWN, A TOTAL FLOP.
DESPITE HEALTH HYSTERIA,
KAVANAUGH WILL FINALLY GET THE
FEATURED ROLE HE DESERVES,
AND HE'S PREPARED FOR IT HIS
ENTIRE LIFE.
A SEED OF THE SUPREME COURT OF